un derby vinoy pour ce 5e tour de la
coupe de france ce trappe qui évolue en
ph recevait les mureaux une équipe de dh
trois divisions dessus des trappistes le
match débute mal pour les saint
quentinois la 19e minute de jeu.les
muriautin marque après un cafouillage
un but qui donne des ailes aux verts la
défense trappistes doit s'employer à
plusieurs reprises pour éviter le but du
break avant la mi temps ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on a à peu près le
même groupe la même défense après
attrape on a toujours eu l'esprit
guerrier donc voilà ça se ressent qui
aujourd'hui sur tous les autres matchs
au retour des vestiaires trappe revient
avec de meilleures intentions et fait
jeu égal avec les bureaux et rouge
exerce un gros pressing et monopolise le
ballon on perd 1 0 à la mi temps on a un
peu de mal à rentrer dans le match
bon on a été un peu secoué la mi temps
on avait dit qu'on n'avait rien à perdre
pas de pression et on la joue un peu
plus libéré du conscience a ressenti sur
la 2 e mi temps malgré le jeu développé
sur la seconde période les mureaux
marque à la 80e minute sur corner 2-0
trappe réduit le score dans les
dernières minutes sur penalty par
hamidou sissoko un but anecdotique les
verts l'emportent 2 1 et se qualifie
pour le 6e tour
c'est une défaite logique donc l'écart
de nouveau trompé la chine d'acheter bur
abordant la maîtrise
sang froid ils ont marqué dans les
banques les banques après nous on essaie
d'exister
l'écart entre une ps1 dh on prend le
deuxième but sur un coup de pied arrêté
à dix minutes de la fin
ça joue sur des détails voilà il ya on a
vu la différence de niveau sur le
deuxième but maintenant c'est à nous de
bosser pour un pouvoir les rejoindre un
jour tu rappes va à présent refermer
cette parenthèse coupe de france pour se
reconcentrer sur le championnat
les joueurs d'arnaud mbj son douzième de
ph après trois journées disputées